au travail et qui fait la meilleure
cuisine les hommes ou les femmes les
hommes
pourquoi
ils ont plus goût à la cuisine
les femmes savent pas faire la cuisine
pour tellement doute maintenant avons
maintenant
on sait que les hommes savent faire la
cuisine normalement dans les restaurants
quand même ce sont les hommes les plus
grands cuisiniers je poursuis en exemple
vous ne visez pas de femmes dans les
grands restaurants à la cuisine je crois
que c'est très dur comme métier ça
dépend des femmes et celle des hommes
les amants en principe ce sont les
hommes parce qu'ils ont beaucoup plus
patiente une flamme les femmes les
femmes
les femmes et femmes les hommes
s'apprêtent à la cuisine j'aime faire la
cuisine mais c'est pas si bien oh
certainement les au
palais beaucoup plus fins sans aucun
problème ma femme fait bien la cuisine
je pense que les femmes sur la cuisine
maison sont plus qualifiés que les
hommes si on regarde les cuisiniers
professionnels on est tenté de dire ce
sont les hommes enfin quand on est là en
famille on est tenté bien ce sont les
femmes peut-être
d'un berger à la bergère en finale on
vous regarde travaillons dans la
pression que le chef de la maison c'est
bien vous mais moi oui oui chef dans ma
cuisine surtout mais comment la partie
pour dix chefs cuisinent r
oui je veux bien enfin moi
personnellement je ne me considère pas
comme un chef je vous considère comme
une cuisinière bon après mes clients mes
cuisines ya surtout monsieur denis est
ce que les femmes savent faire la
cuisine à votre avis
la cuisine c'est aussi savoir dans
quelles conditions la leur fait faire
monsieur jacques manière comment se
fait-il selon vous qu'il y ait peu de
femmes dans les cuisines de restaurant
et qu'il n'y en ait pas du tout dans
votre établissement bon alors je
voudrais pourrez tout de suite comment
se fait-il qu'il n'y ait pas eu de
chasseurs à l'époque de chasseuse de
chasseresses l époque politique parce
que il y avait un combat et la cuisine
c'est quand même un combat estime des
raisons pour lesquelles qui a très peu
de femmes dans la cuisine et il n'y a
jamais eu beaucoup de femmes dans la
cuisine à travers les âges mais par
contre il y a eu des cuisinières
mesdames est ce que vous considérez
comme un grand chef non comme une très
bonne cuisinière clément la pierre vous
appartenez à la nouvelle génération de
chefs cuisiniers est-ce que vous pensez
que les femmes ont leur place au milieu
de la grande cuisine
et bien dans le contexte actuel de la
cuisine je pense que les femmes ont leur
place mais il faut dire que la cuisine
depuis quelques temps depuis 3 4 ans a
beaucoup changé beaucoup évolué et on a
simplifié la plupart des plats madame
massiat devant la misogynie de certains
chefs cuisiniers quel genre de réaction
avec nous
je ne suis pas perçu la misogynie des
cuisiniers je connais avec tous les
grands chefs les autres n'ont évidemment
mais on ne fait pas de moquer maintenant
les conditions de travail pour les
femmes et pour les hommes sont
naturellement différent parce que leurs
moyens physiques sont différents ce
n'est pas du tout leurs moyens
intellectuels ou leurs moyens
professionnels qui sont en cause il est
évident que l'on voit mal des femmes
soulever des randos de 50 kg pourquoi
selon vous madame massiat n'y at-il pas
beaucoup de femmes qui font la cuisine
dans les restaurants parce qu'elles ne
savent pas qu'elles peuvent la faire
madame carnet vous êtes l'une des six ou
dix chefs cuisiniers reconnus à paris
est ce que vous avez l'impression
d'exercer un métier qui ne vous
appartient pas vraiment
non
ces métiers peut aussi bien convenir à
une femme du k1 hommes je ne vois pas du
tout la différence les femmes est un
bourg où ils font la cuisine
y en a beaucoup mais enfin pas tellement
il y en a c'est à dire que maintenant et
elle a quand même un peu moins parce que
c'est très dur pour une femme lorsque
vous avez 50 kg a porté à bout de bras
vous ne pouvez pas demander à une dame à
part quelques exceptions et si nous
voulons un petit peu nous retourner sur
le passé et bien regardons un petit peu
la morphologie de cuisinière est long
des hanches comme ceci moi j'ai
l'impression d'être un haricot vert à
côté le matériel n'est pas étudiée pour
les femmes mais elles savent quand même
très bien s'en servir nous avons
beaucoup de choses dans la vie qui est
différente le mât et c'est très
difficile qu'une fable se considère dans
une brigade où il faut lui même
on n'est jamais là l'heure des repas
dont 10 jamais là lors de se coucher
c'est toujours des gens qui sont tout à
fait différents est-ce que vous
personnellement vous accepteriez de
travailler avec une femme ici dans votre
cuisine
bien disons que
vous me posez une colle parce que
je ne sais pas si ça pourrait vraiment
collé parce qu'une femme ses idées ou un
gilet mieux non je ne veux pas d'homme
on ne sait pas le même travail je sais
que pour une femme la cuisine je crois
que c'est une vocation c'est pas un
métier il faut aimer ça tandis qu'à
l'homme il apprend la cuisine souvent
par force parce que l'on me dise est un
bon métier valeur pourriez vous
m'expliquer comment vous est venue à
faire de la cuisine de la restauration
et bien même temps que ça il ya 30 ans
dès que je ne suis marié je me suis mise
à faire la cuisine
et vous avez pris ça comme ans et j'ai
appris à faire la cuisine avec ma mère
et ma belle mère qui tenait également un
restaurant non pas moi même et ma belle
mère tenait le restaurant et j'ai été à
bonne école avec et c'est elle qui m'a
pratiquement tout appris mais si vous
voulez la cuisinière pour moi est un peu
au stade ménagers et sur le stade
professionnel au stade professionnel la
ménagère
et la cuisinière il y a eu très peu de
cuisinière qui ont pu vraiment réaliser
une cuisine dite de cuisine qu'est ce
qui distingue chose écran brisé il faut
avoir l'honnêteté de dire qu'ils sont
tous allés en apprentissage chez la mère
brazier les grands cuisine chez les
merlus
qui a commencé la crise monsieur alain
senderens est ce qu'un grand chef comme
vous pourrez envisager la présence de
femmes dans ses cuisines oui totalement
souvent des cartes nous demande de faire
un stage et j'ai refusé on est pas un
chef cuisinier misogyne non pas du tout
la vie il peut pas être isolé il voyant
il ne serait pas le but mais c'est pas
possible ça c'est pas possible la
cuisine c'est l'amour essentiellement
enfin quand quand un client rien chez
moi
je souhaite comme s'il était mon mari
mon père mon amour mon enfance et je
menais j'aurais eu l'idée de j'aurais
l'idée de faire venir des journalistes
des photographes même quand c'est un
personnage aussi important qu'un
président de la république n'ait pas vu
une seule fois chez moi est venu trois
fois on leur fait - publicité aux
cuisinières ah bon aux femmes qui font
la cuisine on leur fait beaucoup moins
de publicité à votre avis est-ce qu'il
ya des différences entre la cuisine
d'hommes et la cuisine de femme
où il ya des différences justement parce
que généralement le but poursuivi n'est
pas le même
cela je crois la principale raison en
fait les vies et homme le chef de
cuisine au travail un peu comme un chef
d'orchestre je sais que les chefs
comparé leur qu'ils aient la vie
tableaux as des as de la musique pour
moi c'est un homme mais c'est pas un
grand arbre les femmes cuisinent avec
leur tempérament
leur cuisine est beaucoup moins laborie
il rentre juste ce qu'il faut vous
donnez à une femme une poignée de farine
1 1 fait de l'eau elle vous fait une
tarte vous donner à un homme une poignée
de farine a fait de l'eau il ne sait
rien vous faire voilà la différence
qu'il ya entre la femme et l'homme quand
il s'agit de cuisine du généralement
familiale faite dans des restaurants
comme je le disais tout à l'heure de
moyenne importance elles réussissent
parfaitement parce qu'elles sont
toujours très soignée très appliqués
dans ce qu'elles font j'ai toujours dit
à mes apprentis quand il faisait retire
un poulet je vous prie faites m'en la
cuisine de tante marie c'est à dire pour
n'ouvre le four en la rose on tourne
rose etc et on laisse pas le poulet dans
le four bêtement
sans sang maculent b eh bien je fais à
peu près la cuisine que les cuisiniers
se feraient chez eux leurs jours de
repos c'est à dire une cuisine simple de
tradition et qui le rappellerait la
cuisine familiale une femme en général
une l'a pas le génie créateur ne cherche
pas d'ailleurs lui et je pense que sa
cuisine est une cuisine ancestrale on
transmet de mère en fille les recettes
familiales elle recopie un peu un peu
trop textuellement mais je ne pense pas
que la femme sur le plan
créativité en cuisine
apporte véritablement quelque chose et
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que je
reviens toujours à ce que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure la femme défense le foyer
et la cuisine ne s'occupe pas de
l'argent je pense que les femmes ont
beaucoup d'imagination en cuisine ne
serait-ce que les ménagères qui sont
obligés de faire chaque jour un plat
différent avec un budget très limité
non je crois qu'on ne peut pas dire ça
c'est pas possible
là j'étais en train de préparer avec
vous c'est moi qui l'ait imaginer
inventer
entièrement s'est passé c'est une
cuisine de femme c'est un plat qui fait
pas mal à l'estomac qui est très très
léger on parle de nouvelle cuisine si la
nouvelle cuisine existe est ce que ce
n'est pas justement la cuisine de femme
une cuisine simple une cuisine plus
naturel que ce qui a été fait jusqu'à
présent en réalité la cuisine de femmes
souvent on n'est pas tout à fait comme
on dit la cuisine nouvelle parce que la
cuisine de femme est une cuisine
comporter
ajouté alors qu'on l'accusé nouvelle est
une cuisine rapide nous cuisons des
restèrent est ce que les femmes
cuisinières les chef cuisinière comme
vous et
souffre un peu quand même de cette
injustice qu'il ya au départ un p oui
et à tout même une injustice alors
est-ce qu'elles vont s'organiser pour
hiba j'espère bien
j'espère et je voudrais bien que les
femmes
commencent à comprendre que c'est aussi
un métier pour elle
[Musique]